yes
that was your boyfriend durst with the
lighter talk uh
dayton hypernova has been just
disappeared from his youtube channel
and he's figured out a way why is he
titling his videos like a
bit it's really long because that's the
older brother and sister older sister
and brother-in-law interracial couple
bring kids like it just sounds like a
[ __ ] pornhub
title so he's because he was getting
trolled
people were sending him bibles and stuff
um he found a way to still post his
videos
before like so people like us can't find
them but so why do we have them
it's 100 foolproof this system it's
clearly not
and there's no way to get around it and
he's been um
but royce if we found it that means kiwi
farms found it too and that
they will after we talk about it um
no they probably already have their eyes
people are [ __ ] psychopaths
he's been posting his videos on his
facebook page
but putting him unlisted so he thinks
only his facebook friends
good you're gonna see them that's that
is foolproof so let's watch it
um my sister and brother-in-law are
outside right now with their kids
and talking to uh our parents
who are babysitting these kids with uh
our older brother who is a hermitic
alcoholic
skinhead who beats me in this house he's
a skinhead man
no no he's a skinhead sherman's a
skinhead yeah
repeatedly so i keep getting video
footage of this
it's just a nice family day wait
i can already hear it wait till you see
how beautiful it is i can already hear
it it sounds like everybody's like
grandpa's being a grandpa
cooking some hot dogs hanging out with
the kids
hey man you're out the window again yeah
so that's a
get the window again why does he keep
filming me wait till you see wait till
you see
oh this is this wait you'll see i'm
trying remember this one in the next
video but we'll see
it might be this
i think it might be the other video but
so he's just secretly just filming the
black guys
children here to be babysat by that
hermit who beats me who's a skinhead
racist
misogynist transphobic homophobe
all those things trump supporter
well if he's got his black
brother-in-law and his mixed race uh
nieces and nephews there
and he's not doing it he seems to be
doing a terrible job of being a skinhead
he watches the kids for them
sometimes sherman does like he mentions
it too it's like he's not those things
and this man allows him to get to meet
him else's kids babies
what the [ __ ] fold your laundry put it
away i have to avoid people in this
house because of the violence that keeps
happening to me
i have to avoid people because i know
the laundry is piled up because remember
the laundry says drugs it's his job mike
and he's not doing it it doesn't look
like he's doing a good job
he keeps beating me in front of them
in this house
and then he films the kids he's a
[ __ ] weirdo man
that's his sister when one of the
incidents has happened
she knows about this man beating me in
front of her
why don't they keep getting in verbal
fights about him beating me
she refuses to acknowledge that she has
you know
been witnesses even though it keeps
happening even though she drove me to
the
emergency room to and from their
emergency room
because our parents refused to drive me
to the emergency room from a beating
all right um there's there's another
video
that i think is the one i i really
wanted to play this one is crazy all
around
by him uh well it's not this one that's
that's something else i wondered
yeah that was oj's white bronco yeah
that was a good song
that was great and i and i don't want to
actually play that oj's going to come
out with a whole album
he does all right
this video is i think by far his best
one
that's a taller trust me
better than germany it's up there ah i
forgot about that what's up it's up
there what's up the top two
batteries i found some batteries so
let's go put him in the fire truck okay
sounds hard he's in hell
so they're outside with the kids let me
get skip ahead because he films a lot
right now
my sister and my brother-in-law are here
with their small children who are
toddlers and downstairs right now
my older brother is in the living room
very loudly
playing pop music from the 90s
what this is starting to feel like a
coin
he's mad at him for listening to 90s pop
music in his house
he said it in a way where like it was a
bad thing like he was watching
child pornography in front of these kids
like you know what i mean he made it
sound like
my brother's playing pornography on full
blast
5.1 dolby in front of the children okay
you know what you should do
that sounds horrible no it's 90s pop
music
my my brother's playing carlos santana
featuring rob thomas smooth
it's my so we have small small children
in the house
and my brother has the nerve to play
jewel
[Laughter]
let the lyrics keep dreaming keep keep
dreaming
about his future september it's
september
2019 we have small children in the house
and and my brother is playing jagged
little pill by atlanta's more set
in front of the children our goals in
life
he's an enthusiastic man i think because
he listens to pop music non-stop down
there at full blast
and he beats me when i think i'm them
i'm guessing
out of the in the closet too then i mean
i've listened to 90s pop music before
that we all did right
i'm gonna dress around him because he
thinks
people are disgusting and he beats me in
front of these people
and these kids out here these are three
toddlers
and you're the one filming them earl
it's my sister who's a very overweight
woman
what why are you throwing shade at home
what is this what did she
do she's a nice lady actually
about talking about him beating me
in front of her she harassed me for
posting these video diaries
and that's why he hasn't been because
she's
i know for a fact she's seen our videos
and i think she told him
you know they're making fun of you
online right just keep posting them
because this is horrible behavior i keep
getting beat down by a man well over
twice my size
and who's this manuel guy are we gonna
find him brought up her
manual twice this size very weird name
all these people are very much aware of
what's happening
and they keep bringing those kids over
here to be babysat by that man
and he babysits his children and he's
listening to lfo
as we speak and they let him and they
led him
and he's got he's just playing britney
spears
and the kids are around there's kids
around and he's playing barbie girl
picks them up and carries them around
and he's a drunken mess
the entire time he never leaves his
house
he's a hermit he's an alcoholic who
constantly drinks
he refuses to leave the house he's lived
here for more than six years and i've
been getting beat down
you've lived there for like ten the
entire time
by him in front of all of them
constantly regularly
so i never leave the second floor i mean
i stay in my bedroom
where i go up to the how do you do this
like how do you
how do you do like this because he's
mentally ill but also it's been
in they've indulged him for far too long
oh yeah but like even if you don't
indulge this what's the end
what's the end game even if you were
involved and you forced them into mental
health and they were younger like what's
what happens when you just get a [ __ ]
what happens when a
lemon drops out of your wife's
right i mean like like what do you do
you got you got a lemon
you can't return it you can't you can't
yeah but he's functional he's also a
narcissist like he could just leave
but that can't that can't be fixed yeah
you can't fix any you got a [ __ ]
lemon
looming bins bring them back they are
and they're just out there having a good
time well he's listening to loud music
this is great
remember he's been saying how terrible
these people are how horrible they are
how mean they are
but it's because it's a little reversal
so he's filming him that's my sister
right there
the very overweight one he calls jesus
she recently harassed me and physically
bullied me
pushed me around the house okay and here
we go
that's her husband out there my
brother-in-law
who completely slacks about this entire
situation what it was
it's not his problem even if there was a
situation it's a [ __ ] situation but
what like what would that what would you
do
yeah and your brother-in-law's t-pain he
seems nice completely
slacks about this entire situation
he's waving at him he saw through the
window
and he's been so nice
i've been spotted i'm gonna go run some
interference
provide me cover fire i've gotta run
right tire situation
also he doesn't sound like uh no he's
he's
he's very he doesn't sound like he hey
man yeah he doesn't sound like you're
yeah typical fella he's like hey man how
you doing yeah
doing good he does not sound you guys
that's not what i expected to hear
hi nathan how are you how you doing
dayton you doing good howdy
and you know my favorite part is black
guy that says howdy and you're like
where did you learn
they still call him dayton they're even
using his preferred name
hey what's up dayton paradox cipher
whatever
cyberpunk 2077. earlp
in the chat rights stealth check failed
dude you're not good at that
oh [ __ ] that's hilarious hey i thought
it hurt something
yeah oh well oh nothing
the black brother-in-law is like that's
like an oblivion [ __ ] ai
what was that oh that's probably the
exclamation point goes over his head
like metal gear solid blink
i love like in those games so you can
just max out your stealth and have the
right uh
items on it you can be right behind them
hello
i don't see anything
i have to i have to hide this camera
he's panicking he's panicked
and the video ends and he dies it was
that they killed him what if he was
right all along and that was the last
one they murdered
it is so beautiful to see that happen to
him
i honestly feel so bad for the rest of
the goddamn people
they all seem like they don't seem like
you know
the perfect people but who is but they
just seem like a family it was like
bring the kids over
have a couple of goddamn hot dogs you
know what i mean like
there's there's a certain point where
people like this just gets
so [ __ ] overwhelmed like you have to
stop like i'd be like you gotta go man
it's just people we're gonna have a
hangout man
put the shitty uh uh inflatable pool
outside for a little while
eat some hot dogs why are you gonna ruin
everything
this guy's just trying to listen to us
now that's what i call music five
downstairs and he's being yelled at like
my family's
all dysfunctional every single one of
them but there's nobody who's so [ __ ]
up that they
like there's like you know i mean i have
family that like tries to not do
too many drugs and [ __ ] on holidays and
try to be at least like a
like hey what's up how are you god it's
good everybody's like nobody's bringing
weird [ __ ] up
everybody like even my family is like
look it's chris we can't [ __ ] stop
we're like hey we're just trying to have
a barbecue the grandkids are here
no this this is insanity and
like again even if everybody's family's
a little dysfunctional
this level of like you're ruining
everybody's day and it's like
hey you know me me and me and the
husband are gonna bring the kids over
we're just gonna hang out if you guys
want to have lunch ah it sounds nice
there's some pressure pressure to the
depression it's like jesus man but
imagine living in a house where
somebody's secretly filming you all the
time like that has to be
and your children like that has to be
tiring like enough man